có phương tiệt tham gia kìm định.
Cục đăng kìm định Nam Chò biết có khoảng hơn 3 phẩy sau chiệu lượt.
Phương tiệt đặt tiêu tròn át tỏnh kỹ thuật và mở bị mù tròn.
Hơn Nam Cham lại từng nghiên lượt phương tiện,
tức và triếm miha và hình trăm không đặt,
phải mạo giữa sử chó điều trình để kìm định lại.
Lối kìm phương tiện chờ tìm định nhiều nhất,
vẫn là lỗi gió hệ thông phán định.
Đây, dễn, Cục đăng kìm định Nam Chò biết cả nước hiện có 3 xam lại.
Bà trên bà trong bùi tám cơ sử đăng kìm và chi nhà ngó độ bưới Nam Cham lại chiến,
trên Nam Cham tà mới bà dây chuyên kìm định.
Đăng bệnh hành.
Tò hệ thông có hơn 2 gình đăng kìm viên xa cơ dối,
và Nam Chúc chỉ có đăng kìm viên xa mấy chuyên dông đang làm việc trên cả nước.